Hello Freak bitches.
We're not like in a,
I'm not like in a position where I'm going to have an actual battle with someone
yet.
I don't know.
You're right,
but but,
but for competition,
no self defense.
Self defense.
I mean like I like,
see then you can't say that because that could happen on the way to the grocery
store.
Oh my God.
You can run into some crazy messed up chick wants a fucking do get out.
Literally
like we're doing this.
I wish I had the fucking manpower literally to like we were in Nashville like
two weeks ago for Americana Fest.
We're playing this festival and we were driving under this bridge and there were
these two guys beating the fuck out of each other in the middle of the street.
It was like a bottle over the face.
This one guy was choking the other guy and anchor.
No,
terrible.
It was sloppy.
Crackhead,
bullshit.
Main puzzles.
It was like,
obviously we called the police,
but like I had this moment where I was like,
I wanted to do something.
I'm like,
what the fuck can I do?
And I was literally the leaned out the window and I went stop.
I didn't know what to do.
And I called the police.
But like if I were a new job,
like you
definitely stayed in my car,
right?
100%
if you're driving by two people beating the fuck out of each other,
you are not there.
Okay.
You were in a car just because it's right in front of you.
That shit could be a hundred miles away in less and less.
There's someone in that mixture that needs you.
Like if there's someone who's small and they get beaten up by someone big,
then everything changes.
But if it's too fucking dude chill from the other day,
they're fighting in the street fucking so my point is don't always stop.
Just kiss already.
Don't always stop.
Sometimes you get to elect two dudes beat each of the day.
It's better for everybody.
Certain people,
it's fine.
Just give him both rocks and push them near the edge.
Go
let them fall and keep coal mining.
You got to keep moving.
Okay.
Genes need to flourish.
They need to find better streams of diversity.
That's what I'm saying,
man,
don't always stop fights.
And what I've realized is when they,
when they've recognize you as a threat,
when they identify you as somebody who could do them damage,
they start going on maneuvers trying to find out everything about it.
You're trying to find out what the worst stuff they have on you is so that he
can dismiss you as a bigot or a sexist or a Neo Nazi or whatever.
They can come up with anything they can grasp out because their strategy is to
dismiss the,
is to dismiss the speaker by attacking the speakers credibility.
Because that way they never have to even consider the merits of the argument.
Yes.
They haven't been able to do that with me.
Um,
which is why feminists now refuse to bait me,
debate me on TV because they know they'll lose.
Um,
they calm,
bring out,
well they can't bring out,
they've got this battery of dismissing of a dismissal tactics that they've
amassed over the last 30 years and they've got so complacent because they've
never had,
you know,
a Sassy gay person.
And come up and say it,
you're talking bullshit and you're hurting men and here are the facts.
They've never had it before.
So they've never built up an arsenal to fight it.
Um,
you know,
so this is,
this is why I went and while Cook I'll keep winning because they don't really
know how to deal with an argument on its own merits.
And in any case,
of course the facts are on our side.
Well,
it's also this conversation that we're having right now is about war.
You're saying winning and losing and they're taking tactics and strategies to
look up dirt on the opposition.
They're going,
they're treating.
This is,
it's,
this is an ideological war is not a debate about the facts of the issue.
And I think that's part of it because the left has always seen this as a war.
And the gender warriors,
you know,
have always been warriors.
They've always seen this in strategic terms.
I'm not sure.
People on Conservatives and naturally more self effacing conservatives tend to
be a little bit cool,
a little bit more chill about things they kind of don't really want to get of.
How do you explain?
I think they get very angry about things.
Ted Cruz,
what am I saying?
Old Conservatives,
but he explained,
what's her name?
Pailin chick.
Sarah Pailin.
How to explain that.
These are the,
these are the outline is that even most conservatives find these people a bit
much.
How could be,
I think that guy's in his,
in the end.
Who knows how these much fatter now he was hopping when last time.
I mean,
you know,
for like a lazy Christian TV gigs,
so fat he got so far,
I cannot vote for anyone.
That phenomena of rock and rolling.
I Want Marco Rubio just because he's hot.
If we call out Trump,
then I won't regret it.
I don't think.
I think people are silly.
So whether or not it's a conservative thing or a liberal thing,
I think there's a vast majority of people that aren't not very good at looking
at themselves.
And they're not very good at looking at the momentum of their actions.
They just think that they're right because this is what they've,
they've been saying for so long.
And I think that's one of the most horrific things about these conversations
with these women.
Get in with you about,
cause like when,
when they're talking about what they think are social constructs,
things like gender identities and the way people be.
And when you shatter that with the facts,
they're looking for some other weapons and there's nothing there or you see it
in their eyes.
You know,
cause it's not really a debate about the idea itself.
It's just not what,
it's not.
What it's about is gender warfare.
That's why people like Christina Hoff summers called them gender warriors
because these aren't people who want any kind of social justice as they say.
These are people who just hate men,
will just hate men.
They want to hurt men.
Um,
they don't want to quality for women.
They want to,
they want superiority for women.
Whether it's architected into the education system or you know,
affirmative action or whatever it is.
They don't want quality.
They want superiority.
And fundamentally,
a lot of this,
you know,
these,
these crazy extremist,
you know,
uh,
progressive third wave feminists,
today's version of feminism.
It basically boils down to [inaudible] and it takes a gay guy because it's so
dangerous for men to even broach this subject anymore.
And any man,
a mainstream job puts that at risk by even talking on the subject no matter what
his opinion is.
Um,
it takes a gay guy to go on,
you know,
Sky News in the UK and say,
I'm sorry,
the facts are not on your side and what you're doing is damaging to women.
Um,
it's to me really an indictment on a,
on debate in our public square that it is so dangerous for a man to even express
an opinion on this subject that it takes a fact they're going to stick up for,
for heterosexuals.
If other men could say this,
they would be,
but they can't because they would run the risk of their careers.
Feminists always talking about silencing the people.
Icy silence to men,
but we don't,
there's no like established number that everybody knows like,
oh,
if you eat this,
you how many milligrams are you had 10 oh,
you're fine.
There's because of the fact that it's illegal.
There's all this guessing and you gotta.
It takes a long time to figure it out.
You've got to talk to a bunch of different people and get answers.
Don't talk to Joey Diaz throwing off the curve or don't worry about a cop
soccer.
Even though the one you're going to walk on ice,
you might as well dance.
I saw him the other day on periscope just eating.
He's like,
all right,
here,
take this,
and he's like,
they're eating just tons of edibles and then they're like,
all right,
you [inaudible] you've never done acid.
Well,
open up your tongue here and they just drop acid.
Eight ish.
Yeah.
Joey goes so deep.
He's not even experiencing reality as we know it because reality is just very
different right now.
Where to lead.
This guy's like,
oh,
I guess ass eating that much as normal.
He enjoys it.
He's turning him into a Jody is.
Yeah,
but listen man,
think about if you're Li,
right.
Nice kid.
Very smart guy.
He's a sweetheart.
Funny on the show.
And this fucker has stumbled into a partnership with the funniest man that's
ever lived.
So he has this podcast,
the funniest man that's ever lived.
What is the funniest man that's ever lived?
Do he doses them every day?
Joey Diaz doses that guy with like 500 milligram Chiba Chews.
He'll take the wrapper off of a fucking 200 milligram Chiba Chew,
put a 500 milligram in their rapid wrap it handed to him,
eat a dog the mile,
the mile done line about the fucking number two hundreds normal.
The line about the number,
they say 200 get the fuck outta here to Honda with your fucking faggy 200 I had
like a 40 the other day or something like that.
I was fucked up out of book.
I can't believe they let Lee thinks 200 is a normal number,
you know?
Yeah.
Those guys go deep.
He had to death stars the other day too,
to death stars too.
I've never even heard of anybody eating two of those things.
Do you ever heard of the death star?
Oh my God.
Is it?
There's some fucking thing that these guys in northern California,
Maine,
I think the same guys who make the gummy bears make the,
uh,
the death stars and they're supposed to be so bad.
Joey was running,
trying to give one to Alex Jones last time we were in Austin together.
Where's Alex Jones?
I got to get him one of these desktops.
Joe Rogan.
I'm going to get them one of these desktops.
I'm gonna fuck him up.
Last time he had like a of bread
gummy where he was cutting slices for amazing.
I gotta make slice you off on and
like,
you ready to fucking Deli with them?
Hey,
you got to try this.
No pressure.
I got this new pursued.
All this fucking guy knows on a make a good pursuit.
Okay.